hello everyone and welcome back to
Simply learns YouTube channel I hope you
guys are doing well have you ever
thought about starting a career in cloud
computing but don't know how to begin
several people recently asked us about
how to get started so we did some
research and created this roadmap so
here we are with a video on cloud
computing roadmap for 2024. if you also
want to become a cloud computing expert
then this video is for you it's meant to
help you learn the skills and knowledge
you need for a job in cloud computing
but before we begin if you enjoy
watching these videos and find them
interesting then consider subscribing to
Simply learns YouTube channel because we
bring the best videos for you did
also hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from Simply loan also do check
out the cloud architect Masters program
by simplylearn this program will help
you build your AWS Microsoft Azure and
Google Cloud platform expertise from the
ground up you'll learn to master the
architectural principles and services of
the top Cloud platforms design and
deploy highly scalable fault tolerant
applications and develop skills to
transform yourself into an AWS and Azure
Cloud expert this program will give you
an in-depth understanding of cloud
services such as AWS cloud formation
Azure resource manager ec2 S3 Route 53
VPC Azure app services gcp and more you
will acquire the Knowledge and Skills
for passing Cloud architect
certifications such as AWS architect and
Azure architect
candidates with OnePlus years of work
experience are preferred to enroll in
this program so check out the link
mentioned in the description box below
for more details so without any further
delay let's start this video with what
is cloud computing cloud computing in
simple terms refers to the practice of
using remote servers on the internet to
store manage and process data instead of
relying solely on your local computer
it allows you to access your files
applications and services from anywhere
with an internet connection providing
convenience scalability and flexibility
for individuals and businesses alike so
let's move on to the cloud computing
roadmap for 2024. the first step in this
roadmap is foundation of cloud
Begin by understanding the fundamental
concepts of cloud computing learn what
cloud computing is its history and why
it's essential in modern ID
familiarize yourself with different
cloud service models iwas infrastructure
as a service learn about Cloud
infrastructure components like virtual
machines storage and networking pass
understand platforms that allow
developers to build deploy and manage
applications without worrying about the
underlying infrastructure SAS software
as a service explore software
applications delivered over the Internet
such as email collaboration tools and
CRM systems get to know about various
Cloud deployment models public cloud
cloud resources are owned and operated
by a third-party cloud service provider
and are made available to the general
public private cloud cloud
infrastructure is dedicated to a single
organization and can be located on
premises or hosted by a third-party
provider hybrid Cloud combines public
and private Cloud environments allowing
data and applications to be shared
between them the second step is core
cloud services choose a cloud provider
for example AWS Azure gcp or others and
start exploring their core services for
example if you are using AWS learn about
Amazon ec2 for creating virtual machines
understand Amazon S3 simple storage
service for object storage get
acquainted with Amazon VPC virtual
private Cloud for networking in the
cloud practice setting up and managing
these Services through the cloud
providers console or command line
interface
the next and the third step in this
roadmap is networking and security
deepen your knowledge of cloud
networking explore Concepts like vpcs
virtual private clouds subnets IP
addressing and routing understand how to
set up secure communication between
Cloud resources and on-premises network
learn about Cloud security best
practices dive into identity and access
management IAM for user and resource
Access Control explore encryption
mechanisms for data security configure
security groups and network ACLS Access
Control lists for controlling traffics
the fourth step or the next step in this
roadmap is containers and orchestration
gain expertise in containerizations and
orchestration Technologies start with
Docker for creating and managing
containers move on to kubernetes for
container orchestration scaling and
management understand how to deploy and
manage containerized applications in a
cloud environment the fifth step in this
roadmap is serverless Computing explore
serverless Computing Services provided
by your chosen cloud provider ews Lambda
Azure functions Google Cloud functions
Etc learn how to create functions
trigger them and build serverless
applications the sixth step in this
roadmap is storage and databases delve
into various cloud storage options for
example object storage example Amazon S3
Azure blob storage and block storage for
example Amazon EBS Azure disk storage
then Master Cloud databases including
manage databases services like Amazon
RDS and Azure SQL database
the seventh step in this roadmap is
devops and automation Embrace devops
practices for efficient deployment and
development learn about CI CD continuous
integration and continuous deployment
pipelines explore infrastructure as code
tools like AWS cloud formation or
terraform for automating infrastructure
provisioning the eighth step in this
roadmap is monitoring and optimization
understand how to monitor Cloud
resources use cloud native monitoring
and logging Services setup alerts and
notifications for resource health and
performance then optimized resource
usage to control costs and improve
performance the ninth step in this
roadmap is Advanced topics depending on
your interest and career goals explore
Advanced Cloud topic such as machine
learning and AI in the cloud big data
and analytics using cloud services
internet of things in the cloud the next
and 10th Step In This Cloud Computing
roadmap for 2024 is real world projects
and practice apply your knowledge by
working on real world Cloud projects
either independently or as is a part of
Team join online Cloud communities or
forums to learn from others share
experiences and seek guidance from
others the 11th and next step in this
roadmap is continuous learning stay
updated with the latest developments in
cloud computing through books online
courses webinars and conferences
consider pursuing Cloud certifications
offered by Cloud providers to validate
your skills and knowledge and the last
step for this cloud computing roadmap of
2024 is certifications
depending on your career goals aim for
Relevant Cloud certifications to
demonstrate your expertise to potential
employers for example the cloud
architect Masters program pgp in cloud
computing and the cloud computing
bootcamp you can find these courses
mentioned in the simply learns website
and you can also check out the
description box for more details on
cloud architect Masters program as a
cloud Enthusiast you will have diverse
career opportunities so let's explore
some of the potential rules and growth
paths in cloud computing the first is
cloud administrator Cloud experts
oversee and manage a company's Cloud
infrastructure including policies
security protocols uptime monitoring and
technology updates the average salary of
a cloud administrator goes up to 95 000
per annum in the United States and 7.75
lakhs in India with some additional cash
benefits the next job role we have is
cloud infrastructure engineer this role
focuses on designing and managing the
underlying infrastructure of cloud
platforms ensuring scalability security
and performance the average salary of a
cloud infrastructure engineer goes up to
142 000 per annum in the United States
and it goes around rupees 7.68 lakhs in
India with some additional cash
compensation the next job role we have
is Cloud solution architect Cloud
solution Architects design and Implement
cloud-based solutions for organizations
they analyze business requirements and
develop architectural designs to meet
specific needs the average salary of a
cloud Solutions architect goes up to 176
thousand dollars per annum in the United
States and in India it goes around 21
lakh rupees per annum with some
additional cash benefits the last job
role we have in today's video is that of
a cloud security engineer Cloud security
Engineers specializes in securing Cloud
infrastructure and services they
Implement Robo security measures monitor
for vulnerabilities and respond to
security incidents the average salary of
a cloud security engineer goes up to 121
thousand dollars per annum in the United
States and 11 lakh rupees in India with
some additional cash compensations the
salaries in any of these fields are
lucrative and fascinating remember that
mastering cloud computing is a
continuous journey and hands-on
experience is crucial Taylor your
learning path based on your goals and
stay curious and adaptable in this ever
evolving field well that's our app on
this video on cloud computing roadmap
for 2024. we hope you found this video
informative and helpful you should Now
understand how to make a career in this
exceptionally growing field if you are
interested in learning more about
different Technologies there are plenty
of resources available at simply loan
you can also check out our website for
more information on different
certifications if you have any doubts
related to any of the topics we have
covered in this video then please feel
free to drop them down in the comment
section below and a team of experts will
definitely answer them for you so thank
you for being here with us today we'll
see you next time until then keep
learning and stay tuned to Simply learn
for more updates
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here